Messieurs chers collègues j'ai l'honneur
de remplacer le président Stefan Artano
qui vous prie de l'excuser parce qu'il
est actuellement en route pour
Saint-Pierre et Miquelon
je rappelle que dans le cadre de son
étude sur le foncier agricole dans les
outre-mer la délégation à sénatoriale
aux outre-mer c'est pas chez
précédemment sur la situation en Guyane
et à Mayotte et que tany Mohamed soit
lui et moi-même nous sommes rendus en
tant que rapporteur à la Martinique nous
abordons ce matin la situation à la
Réunion puis cet après-midi celle de la
Guadeloupe nous accueillons donc en
visioconférence pour le département de
La Réunion Monsieur Serge Hoarau premier
vice-président du conseil départemental
en charge des affaires agricoles pour la
direction de l'Alimentation de
l'Agriculture de la forêt Monsieur
Jacques parodie directeur accompagné de
Monsieur Bertrand
chef de service en charge du foncier
agricole
pour l'établissement public foncier
monsieur Jean-Louis Grandvaux directeur
pour la chambre d'agriculture Monsieur
Bruno Robert premier vice-président
accompagné de Monsieur Johnny directeur
général
pour l'achat faire Monsieur Thierry
bonjour Henriette
Président Directeur Général accompagné
de Monsieur Arist Lauret directeur
général délégué pour l'ONF monsieur
Sylvain et on a directeur régional et
pour le syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs
monsieur Guillaume sellier Président
nous vous remercions messieurs pour
votre disponibilité dans un premier
temps vous allez avoir la parole dans
l'ordre que je viens dénoncer pour une
dizaine de minutes chaque heure pour
votre propos liminaire pour celui-ci une
trame de questions vous a été adressé et
vous pourrez vous en inspirer sur la
partie correspondant à vos missions
en tant que rapporteur mon collègue tany
Mohamed soit lit en visioconférence et
moi-même pourra intervenir à tout moment
afin de solliciter des précisions
complémentaires de votre part ensuite je
donnerai la parole à ceux de vos
collègues qu'il a demanderont mais avant
de débuter par Monsieur Aro je vais
peut-être demander à mon collègue Tani
Mohamed Souali qui est en
visioconférence si il est là parce que
je crois qu'il ne peut être avec nous
que pour quelques instants
Tani est-ce que tu nous entends
je t'entends très bien est-ce que tu
m'entends oui oui pas de souci
oui chers collègues et mesdames et
messieurs
bonjour effectivement je suis en
circonscription à Mayotte à côté à côté
de la réunion je suis avec intérêt ces
travaux vivaient et moi sommes
rapporteur dans le cadre de ce rapport
très très important
malheureusement nous avons ici une
réunion de crise sur l'eau et je ne vais
pouvoir rester avec vous que quelques
instants mais mesdames et messieurs vous
êtes en très bonne compagnie et avec
intérêt nous suivons ces travaux du jeu
de Lopez et moi merci beaucoup bonne
très bonne réunion et à très bientôt
merci Annie on te souhaite bien du
courage parce que avec tous les soucis
que tu as là-bas à Mayotte je on est
avec par la pensée avec toi
voilà je vais vous donner tout de suite
la parole à Monsieur Waro le premier
vice-président du conseil départemental
de la Réunion en charge des affaires
agricoles monsieur je vous donne la
parole
merci madame la sénatrice bonjour à
celles et ceux qui nous ont rejoints je
vous remercie d'abord de prendre ce
temps pour échanger avec nous sur la
problématique du foncier agricole en
outre-mer et nous allons bien évidemment
faire un focus sur la Réunion et par
rapport à
votre question à vos différents
questionnements d'abord je voudrais
rappeler que nous sommes à la Réunion
dans dans sur un territoire contraint
puisque nous devons 2/3 du territoire et
soumis à différentes réglementations il
reste un tiers à peu près pour les
différentes aménités humaines et
notamment pour l'agriculture avec ses 40
300042000 hectares aujourd'hui 38000
puisque avec effroi j'avais découvert au
mois d'octobre dernier qui avait eu une
diminution de la SAU de 4000 hectares en
disant et cette diminution est
peut-être à l'emprise
urbaine mais également un plus un
sentiment à l'abandon de certaines
terres agricoles qui fait qu'on a chuté
c'est sur ces 10 dernières années de
4000 hectares donc c'est un sujet qui
interpelle et c'est difficulté sont
peuvent être le fait de plusieurs
phénomènes
difficultés d'abord pour nos amis
agriculteurs de continuer à exploiter
etc parce que moi difficulté de main
d'oeuvre difficulté de traitement Phyto
pharmaceutiques qui rendent difficile
notamment le bon entretien de certains
terrains et puis sans doute aussi lié à
des agriculteurs qui sont en fin de
carrière et qui ne retrouvent pas
forcément preneur à leur exploitation ce
qui pose après une de la transmission du
foncier agricole
et cette j'ai découvert avec effroi
pourquoi parce que parallèlement nous
menons une politique
foncière je dirais plutôt dynamique sur
le territoire de La Réunion c'est pour
cette raison ces chiffres m'ont
complètement interpellé et mon surpris
parce que par parce que comme je disais
le collectivité départementale nous
avons mis en place un dispositif pour
pouvoir notamment remettre en culture un
certain nombre de terre en friche avec
des
primes pour les propriétaires
non-exploitants de terrain en friche et
on a avec le dispositif du département
depuis 2014 remis encourager la remise
en culture de 522 hectares avec des
projets d'installation ou encore des
projets d'agrandissement nous avons
également
en lien avec la SAFER la conduite de la
procédure terrain culte et là également
par le biais de cette procédure nous
avons sur les dernières années pu mettre
un certain nombre de terrain remis à
remettre en terrain à cet angle de
culture grâce à cette procédure c'est
une moyenne environ de 320 hectares par
an donc si je prends les 10 dernières
années 320 hectares ça me fait 3200
quand je perds 4000 de l'autre côté ça
m'interpelle et ça m'interroge donc vous
voyez bien que il y a un espèce de vase
communicant qui
dans le delta est négatif et c'est
extrêmement surprenant et pénalisant
pour pour l'activité agricole à la
Réunion donc il y a des procédures
friche qui sont menés la procédure
réglementaire la procédure qui encourage
pour faciliter avec des incitations
financières le la mise en culture d'un
certain nombre de parcelles donc vous
voyez bien que il y a chez nous
une volonté affirmée de la part de la
collectivité départementale de de
travailler sur la remise en culture des
terres en friche ça c'est un premier
point sur c'est un premier constat que
moi je voulais soulever la problématique
de main d'oeuvre et de plus en plus
prégnante sur notre territoire notamment
pour les cultures de grande surface
comme la canne mais aussi pour culture
liée au maraîchage ou à l'activité
fruitière nous avons également cette
difficulté qui est de préparer nos
agriculteurs à la transmission comme les
retraites agricoles si ils n'ont pas une
cotisation complète forcément cette
retraite et moindre et l'agriculteur n'a
pas envie de laisser son exploitation on
peut retrouver des agriculteurs à 67 70
ans toujours chef d'exploitation mais
avec des exploitations en déclin donc
c'est un vrai sujet et concernant la
transmission on voit bien qu'il y a il
nous faut aujourd'hui arriver à mettre
en place un dispositif qui
parce qu'on nous dit tout régulièrement
qu'on installe environ une cinquantaine
de jeunes par an il y a environ 200 qui
sort de son jeunes qui sortent de la des
écoles notamment des lycées mais j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire également dans le
cadre de la réflexion que nous avons
engagé avec les services de l'État la
DAF sur le pack d'orientation agricole
souvent ces jeunes qui sont dans les
lycées agricoles
veulent d'abord et avant tout devenir
chef d'exploitation
directement ou encore continuer dans des
métiers liés à l'agriculture avec un BTS
ou devenir ingénieur
agricole et
d'arrêter les études pour devenir
ouvrier agricole le temps de prendre en
main une exploitation on envoie très peu
donc c'est toute la difficulté alors que
je pense sincèrement qu'il y a un sas de
professionnalisation possible auprès des
agriculteurs qui sont rentrés dans la
phase de transmission si des jeunes
acceptaient d'accompagner ces
agriculteurs peut-être qu'au bout de
quatre cinq ans il pourrait devenir chef
d'exploitation donc il y a un vrai sujet
sur l'accompagnement de nos jeunes au
sortir du lycée agricole au niveau BPA
ou encore BTA pour qu'ils puissent être
accompagné dans le passage d'ouvriers
agricoles à chef d'exploitant agricole
donc c'est un vrai sujet aussi sur
lequel on est en train de réfléchir la
réflexion est engagée et moi j'ai envie
pour terminer
commence quand vous parlez comment
structurer les filières maraîchères à la
Réunion mais j'ai envie de vous dire
cette filière en tout cas chez nous il y
a quand même une partie des agriculteurs
qui travaillent en fruits et légumes qui
sont au sein des coopératives et une
partie qui sont des indépendants à peu
près je dirais
500 600 dans le dans le réseau
coopérateur et 1500 sur le marché de
gros donc on va dire à peu près un bon
tiers en coopérative et deux tiers en
indépendant donc ces filières même quand
c'est de l'indépendant il y a une forme
de filière qui existe parce que quand on
vient livrer ses produits au marché de
gros ça veut dire que derrière il y a
des accapareurs qui ensuite vont
alimenter soit des points fraîcheur soit
des des grandes surfaces soit des la
restauration collective donc il y a une
filière la pour moi elle est pas
structurée de la même manière mais le
marché de groupe est une forme
d'organisation de filière malgré tout
donc c'est là dessus je pense que on
n'est pas aussi bien avancé que que sur
les filières animales mais à la Réunion
je pense qu'il y a quand même un dessin
de d'organisation dans la partie fruitée
légumes qui est assez remarquable et qui
nous permet aujourd'hui de nourrir
tout ou partie de notre population et
également répondre à la demande de la
restauration collective qui est une
demande forte à laquelle on n'arrive pas
forcément à répondre complètement mais
en tout cas il y a cette pour moi la
filière est malgré tout dans une forme
de d'organisation de structuration
la problématique comme maintenant
concernant
la cdp9 concernant la possibilité de
construire sur les terres agricoles et
les demandes des agriculteurs vous savez
pendant très longtemps les maires
étaient en phase avec le monde agricole
pour dire que
il n'était pas normal qu'en métropole ou
la cdp-9 émet un avis simple et qu'à la
réunion nous soyons soumis à la vie
conforme de la cdpna cette position a
tenu tenait jusqu'en novembre de l'année
dernière puisque depuis novembre de
l'année dernière la Chambre
d'Agriculture par la voix de son
président a eu l'occasion de réaffirmer
au moins trois reprises que la chambre
était favorable au maintien de la vie
conforme de la cdp9 une première fois au
conseil d'administration de l'audiadom
en novembre une deuxième fois devant le
ministre des Outre-mer à Saint-Pierre
une troisième fois plus récemment devant
le ministre de l'Agriculture le ministre
des outre-mer et la première ministre
lors de leur dernier passage à La
Réunion donc ça montre bien
qu'aujourd'hui le monde agricole
représentait par la chambre et par la
voie de son président souhaite le
maintien de la vie conforme de la CD
pena si le mandatricone les maires nous
serons nous dans la lignée du
mandaricole puisque si le monde agricole
demande le maintien de la CD P9 la vie
conforme nous allons nous revoir notre
posture par contre ce qu'on va surtout
demander c'est qui est au niveau de la
cdp9
soit on est capable de revoir la
composition de cette cdp9
et également revoir la doctrine de la de
l'application de la mise en oeuvre des
décisions de la cdp-9 qu'on soit bien
clair sur les positions il faut pas
qu'il y ait une forme de main mise de la
Chambre d'Agriculture sur les dossiers
et que seuls les dossiers de la chambre
puissent être accepté validés en CDA
parce qu'il faut garder aussi une
certaine liberté de l'agriculteur de
choisir ou pas de passer par la Chambre
pour déposer un permis concernant une
construction en zone agricole donc ça
c'est important donc il y a une doctrine
je pense qu'il faut réécrire et enfin si
d'aventure nous n'arrivons pas à faire
évoluer la composition de la cdpnaf et
si nous n'arrivons pas également à
réécrire cette doctrine par contrario je
pense qu'on les meta vont demander à
l'État donc à la DAF de faire
l'instruction des autorisations
d'urbanisme en zone agricole et de
délivrer ses autorisations
parce que les maires là dessus on a plus
haut qu'un aucune légitimité puisqu'il y
a la vie conforme de la CD P9 les miens
n'ont plus la légitimité de se prononcer
sur un permis déposé en zone agricole
voilà les quelques éléments introductifs
que moi je voulais aborder avec vous et
[Musique]
on parle sur la requête des agriculteurs
la SPA vous savez qu'il y a eu quelques
évolutions mais je pense que mon
agricole n'est pas concerné compte tenu
du montant de la valeur des
exploitations agricoles et sur l'autre
point le manque d'eau bah écoutez j'ai
envie de vous dire à la Réunion il n'y a
pas de manque d'eau notre problème c'est
de pouvoir gérer cette ressource sur les
12 mois
et pour pouvoir gérer cette ressource
sur les 12 mois il nous faut
avoir je dirais qu'une capacité de à
stocker toute cette pluie qui nous tombe
du ciel je rappelle que nous avons des
records mondiaux de plusieurs métriques
et pour pouvoir ensuite mieux la
distribuer tout au long de l'année donc
c'est pour moi il n'y a pas de manque
d'eau il y a un problème de gestion de
la ressource en eau sur le territoire de
La Réunion parce que il y a des périodes
où nous avons de l'eau à profusion une
période plus sèche et c'est vrai que les
éléments que nous disposons qui nous et
les alertes de de Météo France nous
rappelle que nous allons avoir des
périodes de sécheresse de plus en plus
longues et des périodes plus-vieuses
plus intenses s'il est plus les périodes
plusieurs doivent être plus intenses
nous devons avoir cette capacité de
stocker l'eau qui qui tombe du ciel il y
a une commune qui est exemplaire c'est
la commune du qui a déjà aujourd'hui
construit deux réservoirs de plus de
300000 mètres cubes chacun avec un
troisième réservoir prévu de à plus de
17 millions d'euros d'investissement
mais je pense que cette politique doit
être menée à l'échelle départementale et
retrouver ses capacités de stockage sur
l'ensemble des 24 communes de l'île de
la Réunion pour pouvoir avoir de l'eau
quand on en a besoin notamment en
période de sécheresse pour pouvoir
continuer à irriguer les terres
agricoles donc il y a eu
d'importants chantiers concernant l'eau
à la Réunion les chantiers qui datent
des années fin des années 60 début des
années 70 il y a eu ensuite le grand
chantier
des chantiers des années 70-80 qui ont
créé les périmètres irrigués du du Bras
de la Plaine et périmètre irrigué du
bras de sylaos il y a eu ensuite le
chantier du basculement de l'eau d'est
en ouest en partant depuis Salazie et
aujourd'hui et qui a qui vient irrigué
les électeurs agricoles de l'est près de
6000 hectares de terres agricoles dans
l'est aujourd'hui le réseau dans l'Ouest
les réseaux ouest et sud sont
interconnectés donc il y a un maillage
qui se fait déjà sur plus de la moitié
du territoire nous avons 16000 17000
hectares de dérivés à l'île de la
Réunion et la collectivité
départementales aujourd'hui travaillent
sur un troisième projet qui est le
projet Meren qui vise à pareil prendre
de l'eau sur le secteur de Salazie pour
que pour pouvoir venir irriguer les
terres du Nord s les terres cannières
notamment depuis Sainte-Marie jusqu'à
Saint-Benoît donc voilà un petit peu en
matière ma vision par rapport à la
problématique de l'eau je reste je le
dis il n'y a pas manque d'eau à la
Réunion c'est un problème de stockage et
de gestion de cette ressource sur les 12
mois c'est là dessus qu'on doit
aujourd'hui engager des efforts pour
pouvoir garantir la desserte en eau brut
pour nos agriculteurs et pour le monde
agricole
merci beaucoup monsieur vice-président
je donne tout de suite la parole à
Monsieur Jacques parodie le directeur de
la DAF qui est accompagné de Monsieur
Bertrand Brom chef de service en charge
du foncier agricole messieurs c'est à
vous
merci beaucoup madame la sénatrice alors
je me permets une petite rectification
si vous le voulez bien ce n'est pas
Bertrand Bouron qui est à côté de moi
parce qu'il était indisponible mais
Albert goezzello qui est l'agent en
charge du foncier à la DAF voilà rendons
à César ce qui est à César mais
effectivement c'était Bertrand qui était
prévu initialement alors je vais pas
reprendre la totalité des arguments de
Monsieur le vice-président on a une
analyse qui est assez largement partagée
sur la situation je vais la compléter de
mon du point de vue de l'état de
quelques chiffres donc évidemment le
la préservation du foncier agricole et
la priorité sur le territoire de La
Réunion territoire comme l'a dit le
vice-président extrêmement restreint où
on a une surface agricole utile 450
mètres carrés par habitant soit 10 fois
moins que ce qui existe sur le sur
l'hexagone
et dans cette cette préservation et la
condition sinequanone pour tendre vers
l'autonomie alimentaire et
qui est quand même une des grandes
priorités nationales
la perte du foncier s'analyse sous deux
aspects d'une part
la partie de l'urbanisation et d'autre
part effectivement l'emprichissement des
terres agricoles si on compare les deux
dernières décennies on voit que
la partie
grignotage de l'urbanisme sur les terres
agricoles
évoluent beaucoup moins vite dans les 10
dernières années sûrement grâce aux
outils qui sont en place et qui servent
à préserver cette terre agricole dont la
CD bénaf j'en parlerai tout à l'heure en
revanche la partie en frichement
augmente dans la dernière décennie par
rapport à la décennie précédente
pour autrement ce qui a déjà été dit on
peut estimer que en disant il y a près
de 5000 hectares qui se sont retrouvés
en friche
sur ce et en parallèle on a récupéré
rendu à l'agriculture 2500 hectares mais
ça fait quand même un solde négatif
d'environ 2500 hectares qui ont été
enrichis qui ont été perdus pour
l'agriculture pour les raisons qui a
déjà exposé le vice-président je
rajouterai que c'était qui sont perdus
sont évidemment les terres les moins
favorables celles sur lesquelles il n'y
a pas de mécanisation celle sur lesquels
il n'y a pas d'irrigation celle qui qui
sont les plus difficiles d'accès et
c'est une vraie priorité collective de
regagner cette cet espace agricole sur
ces terres qui qui sont des terres qui
sont qui ont été cultivées et qui
aujourd'hui ont perdu leur
vocation agricole
pour ça il y a plusieurs plusieurs
pistes qu'on peut explorer alors vous
avez dans votre questionnaire évoqué la
problème de la taxation quand je vous
dis que ce sont des terres difficiles ce
sont souvent des agriculteurs en
difficulté
je ne sais pas comment on peut
tirer profit d'une taxation sur ces
terres-là en revanche les dispositifs
qui permettent d'encourager la reprise
de ces terres ceci bien évidemment sont
des leviers qui me paraissent beaucoup
plus
[Musique]
possible de mettre en œuvre
s'agissant de la de l'accès à la terre
pour les jeunes et de la transmission
des exploitations c'est aussi un sujet
qui est préoccupant alors on est un
département français dans lequel
l'installation est dynamique et active
on est un département où on installe le
plus malheureusement les difficultés
existent et les difficultés sont
effectivement
liées à au maintien des agriculteurs qui
arrivent en âge de retraite sur
l'exploitation
essentiellement par manque de revenus la
retraite agricole ne leur permet pas
d'avoir une une
vie correcte au moment où il pourrait
s'exploitation quelles sont les pistes
qu'on peut explorer là-dessus il y a
tout d'abord
ce qui est les accompagnements à la
transmission effectivement des périodes
de transition où le jeûne pourrait
être salarié sur l'exploitation et petit
à petit dans quelques années sur un
intervalle de 3,5 ans prendre la main et
devenir le propriétaire exploitant
une autre solution qui est peut-être
envisageable je ne sais pas si
juridiquement elle est facile et si elle
est possible à mettre en place ce serait
une session sous forme de viager c'est à
dire que le cédant percevrait un petit
complément de retraite le l'accident
aurait des sommes modiques à à verser
pendant les années qui correspondrait à
un loyer mais il aurait la garantie à la
fin de devenir plein propriétaire de
cette exploitation donc ce qui lui
donnerait toute raison pour investir et
pour développer cette exploitation dont
il est sûr de pouvoir
devenir propriétaire à la fin c'est
peut-être une piste qu'il faut
qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder je ne
sais pas
sur la CD P9 alors je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres depuis sa création en
2016 ce sont pas moins de 5000 dossiers
qui ont été de demandes d'autorisation
qui ont été examinées par la CdP
les
je le rappelle n'est une organisation
dans laquelle l'État n'est pas
majoritaire et la décision revient bien
à l'ensemble des membres de la cdp9 et
pas au seul état il arrive fréquemment
que la proposition du rapporteur qu'il
soit de l'État qu'il soit de la de la
Dave quand il s'agit d'espace agricole
ou de la DEAL quand il s'agit de
l'espace naturel au fil de la discussion
au débat du du dossier les les votants
les participants de la CD P9 donne un
avis négatif à la vie qui était proposé
par l'État il arrive aussi et c'est
aussi fréquent que suite aux
explications qui sont apportées
notamment par les représentants des
professions agricoles le rapporteur
lui-même modifie son avis mon avis
défavorable devienne en cours de séance
un avis favorable qui ensuite validé
quand on a des
avis qui concernent le développement
agricole qui sont
rejetées sur une cdp9 c'est souvent par
une incomplètitude du dossier et là sur
une présentation
ultérieure d'un dossier mieux construit
plus complet la Commission peut très
bien sur assez en suivantes redonner un
avis favorable alors qu'elle s'était
précédemment prononcées avec un avis
défavorable
sur le point tout particulier de la
construction d'habitation sur les terres
agricoles alors on peut évidemment
comprendre que un exploitant éleveur a
besoin d'être à proximité de son cheptel
en particulier quand il s'agit de
surveiller les mises bas et les périodes
de reproduction
sur la construction en général j'attire
votre attention sur deux écueils le
premier c'est que le développement de la
construction sur une exploitation
présente un risque je n'ai pas de ces
systématique mais ça peut présenter un
risque de développement d'activités
parallèles de la grotourisme par exemple
de d'Égypte etc qui pourraient je parle
aux conditionnel dans certains cas faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait moins d'intérêt à
exploiter la production agricole qu'a
exploiter la partie touristique d'où un
risque d'avoir l'effet contraire de
celui qu'on attendait c'est de d'écarter
des terres agricoles au profit d'autres
activités d'activité touristiques la
deuxième difficulté que je vois sur la
construction si elle est pas bien
encadrée d'habitation sur la des
exploits sur les terres agricoles c'est
justement au moment de la session
est-ce que le propriétaire cédant va
vouloir garder son bien d'habitation ce
qui va peut-être amener des conflits de
voisinage ce qui va peut-être poser des
problèmes pour nouvelle exploitant ou
est-ce qu'un contrario il va vouloir
céder l'ensemble et mener et conduire à
des coûts d'installation qui deviennent
prohibitifs pour un jeune qui n'a pas
forcément le capital pour s'installer
donc je suis très prudent sur cette sur
cette question de la
des constructions d'habitation sur les
terres agricoles il faut qu'elle soit
parfaitement
encadrée illimité pour éviter le mitage
parce que le mitage est une véritable
plaie je dirais sur l'île de la Réunion
de plus en plus on a des constructions
qui se qui sont érigés au milieu de
parcelle agricole et ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut sur laquelle il
faut il faut le dernier
avantage je dirais de la cdp-9 c'est
aussi que ça permet d'harmoniser les
décisions au sein des 24 communes de
Lille puisque
comme l'a dit le vice-président c'est
bien à la Commission et non pas à l'état
que revient la décision et ce qui permet
d'avoir une position
identique quel que soit le maire et quel
que soit la commune d'installation
considérée
je vous dirai un mot sur le manque d'eau
en affirmant que le changement
climatique est déjà très sensible ici à
la Réunion et plus encore qu'il ne peut
l'être sur le sur le le continent
européen quelques chiffres pour vous
signaler les calamités agricoles
sécheresse 2010 2011 3,3 millions
d'euros ça c'est ce qu'a versé l'État
dans le cadre de
décalamités
sécheresse 2012 3,8 millions d'euros
sécheresse 2013 2,7 millions d'euros
cette sécheresse 2020 3 millions d'euros
sécheresse 2022 3 millions d'euros donc
la question de la sécheresse est
effectuant un seul sujet prégnant à la
Réunion la solution passe évidemment par
la gestion de l'eau par la gestion des
réserves comme l'a expliqué le
vice-président mais elle passe aussi au
semble-t-il par des recherches de
culture qui soient moins consommatrice
en voilà c'est ce que je dirais sur la
sur la partie haut sur la partie
structuration des filières alors
déjà on ne peut pas comparer la filière
fruitée légumes avec la filière canne la
filière canne est forcément une filière
intégrée puisque le planteur ne va pas
produire lui-même son sucre ce qui est
complètement différent dans la filière
fruits et légumes avec la possibilité de
vente directe de la production on a pris
de 70 % de la production qui ne passe
pas
en structuration
néanmoins la les filières structure
puisque on a aujourd'hui 10 au
porganisation professionnelle de fruits
et légumes et une interprofession qui
est la rifle qui est en phase de
reconnaissance au niveau national
c'est un facteur qui faut encourager
parce que la
structuration en filière longue du
producteur au stockage à la
transformation et peut-être à
l'exportation ça peut aller jusque là ça
permet de garantir comme ça se fait sur
les filières viandes un revenu pour le
producteur et ça permet d'avoir une
programmation de la production donc une
approvisionnement régulier des
transformateurs et de la transformation
en fruits et légumes peut encore
largement être développée au niveau de
la Réunion alors quels sont les leviers
pour encourager cette
adhésion aux interprofessions c'est
beaucoup plus difficile je vous l'ai dit
que dans d'autres filières puisque
l'intérêt de l'agriculteur qui vend sa
production en direct n'est pas forcément
évident de voir ce qui peut retirer
d'une d'une interpro et d'une filière
organisée donc il faut qu'il y ait des
c'est interpro soit capable de valoriser
son action et de montrer qu'elle est
d'une part une garantie je dirais une
bouée de sauvetage contre les
différentes aléas de la culture et
d'autre part d'être peut-être un plus en
apporte technique en apport de de sur le
coup des intrants en apport d'un certain
nombre de choses pour les producteurs
voilà j'ai fait un petit peu le tour des
éléments que vous m'aviez
soumis à la dans votre petit
questionnaire je sais pas si Albert veut
rajouter un mot ou si on m'a pris les
deux autres points étaient plutôt enfin
on a des spécialistes à faire et et
qui prend en parler notamment loi
litchimie et puis des recherches de
financement autres donc
on va rester sur ce sur ces points
voilà je suis prêt à répondre à vos
questions bien évidemment si vous avez
besoin de complément très bien merci
beaucoup donc je donne la parole à
Monsieur le Directeur de l'établissement
public foncier monsieur Jean-Louis
Grandvaux monsieur c'est à vous
bonjour bonjour
Moi j'interviens un peu pour vous
présenter ce que l'on fait au niveau de
l'établissement public foncier par
rapport à la politique agricole
c'est-à-dire pas grand chose nous on
intervient surtout sur et uniquement
d'ailleurs
essentiellement sur les terrains qui
sont constructibles on a quand même été
assez bons élèves à la Réunion dans la
mesure où dès 1992 il y a un schéma
d'aménagement régional qui a été voté
qui a été réalisé qui a été réalisé
plusieurs fois et qui a quand même mis
en place des options très intéressantes
pour la filière agricole dans la mesure
où les grands espaces agricoles on a
souhaité les protéger notamment les
espaces gagnés mais aussi maraîchers et
d'élevage et donc on a limité totalement
la construction sur ces espaces afin
d'éviter justement une prolifération des
constructions qui ont créé des mitages
très importants le PF est un outil qui a
été mis en place à la suite
justement de l'approbation de ces
documents d'urbanisme dès 1904 dut 2002
et depuis cette date on a acheté
700 hectares de terrains 900 terrains
auprès de 450 millions d'euros et tous
ces terrains sont des terrains qui sont
des terrains classés constructibles ou à
vocation urbanisation et en aucun cas
des terrains qui sont agricoles donc je
pense que ça concourt à préserver les
autres terrains qui sont des terrains
naturels agricoles et que d'ailleurs la
SAFER qui siège dans notre commission
foncière à l'information complète et
exhaustive de tous les terrains que l'on
achète et aimer des avis sur ces
terrains il nous est d'ailleurs arrivé
d'acheter des terrains à la SAFER qui
n'avaient plus vocation à être agricoles
et qui devenait des espaces constructifs
dans l'avenir
il faut rappeler aussi j'ai été un peu
étonné par les chiffres qui sont avancés
en termes de baisse de la SAU je ne sais
pas s'il est les
statistiques de l'époque étaient
comparables statistiques d'aujourd'hui
moi je me souviens qu'en 1992 en annonce
que 400 hectares de l'espace agricoles
disparaissaient chaque année
je pense que le fait qu'il y a une
volonté commune et partagée des
documents d'urbanisme une politique
urbanisme c'est dynamique dans beaucoup
de communes sur le territoire de La
Réunion a fait qu'on a largement diminué
ces espaces qui ont vocation à être
déclassé d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait
Monsieur le Directeur de la DAF il y a
deux minutes en disant c'est plutôt les
friches qui contribuent qu'il
contribuent aujourd'hui à la baisse de
la SAE certes il y a encore du mitage à
la Réunion pour les espaces pour sur
certains espaces à l'école
[Musique]
des logements sociaux des équipements
publics toutes sortes de d'objets de
construction d'intérêt général et je
pense que ça donne de bons résultats sur
un centre de La Réunion donc
moi je suis pas aussi inquiet que ça par
rapport à en tout cas l'urbanisation
face au monde agricole je pense que on
est on va dans le bon sens c'est que on
n'a pas on n'a pas rougir et que on peut
on peut aller plus loin je suis plus
inquiet justement sur la l'aspect mise
en friche
des certifications de certains
territoires ou peut-être qu'il faut
peut-être trouver d'autres mesures mais
je me sens pas totalement compétent pour
répondre sur ce point là
concernant
concernant le bilan d'activité je vous
ai dit ce qu'il en était
concernant la construction d'habitation
je vous dis la décision courageuse qui
avait été prise et que moi je ne peux
que témoigner mon accord là-dessus c'est
qu'il a été une décision courageuse de
ne pas construire sur les espaces
agricoles notamment gagner ce qui ne se
justifie en aucun cas pour y avoir
quelques particularités sur certains
espaces maraîchers mais sur les espaces
gagnés c'est une bonne chose parce que
c'est vrai que si on ouvrait cette porte
il y a des grandes chances que dans
l'avenir on est quand même une grande
part des espaces canines qui deviennent
plus survins que gagner voilà enfin pour
ce qui est le PF la contribution que je
peux vous donner
pour l'instant et puis je suis à votre
disposition pour des questions
très bien merci Monsieur le Directeur
donc je donne maintenant la parole à
Monsieur Bruno Robert premier
vice-président de la Chambre
d'agriculture qui est accompagnée de
Monsieur Johnny à Paillard le directeur
général c'est à vous messieurs
oui merci beaucoup bonjour madame la
sénatrice déjà j'aimerais commencer par
vous dire que en voyant les questions on
voit bien que le sujet des
problématiques est bien connu puisque
nous ça fait pas mal d'années qu'on fait
du lobby qu'on remonte au
décideurs au niveau national si nos
problématiques et tous ces questions
balayent vraiment le le sujet j'aimerais
en premier lieu donner quelques chiffres
donc qui permettent de bien comprendre
la problématique aujourd'hui un
frontière agricole il estimé entre 1
euro à 2 euros le mètre carré un foncé
constructible il peut aller jusqu'à 200
250 300 350 euros le mètre carré donc ça
c'est un élément à prendre en compte il
y a énormément de spéculation et sur un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
posées cet aspect spéculation va va
jouer un autre chiffre c'est que le la
question du logement puisque tout à
l'heure on va parler du logement
la ministre est venue il y a eu des
chiffres qui ont été communiqués il y a
40000 demandeurs de logement en attente
2002 à la Réunion et ça
10% de plus supplémentaire chaque année
et on est on sort la réunion sort 2000
logements par an donc pour aussi
comprendre la pression qui s'exerce sur
le Foncia la Réunion on a une demande de
logement et d'équipement public qui est
en constante augmentation donc voilà un
petit peu pour les chiffres de départ
j'aimerais pour commencer répondre aux
vice-président du départ de qui est venu
sur le sujet de la de la CdP Peña donc
pour qui a parlé de la Chambre
d'Agriculture effectivement là c'est un
gros enjeu et le maire de médecine le
vice-président département c'est un
maire qui a une très grande sensibilité
rurale c'est le seul pour l'instant la
Réunion avoir mis en place un paon donc
alors oui s'il est 24 maires des 24
communes et dans l'avenir dans le futur
serait comme si elle jouaro on aurait
aucun mal à la Chambre d'Agriculture à
tomber d'accord sur un habit simple en
mettant la confiance dans les mains des
mers pour protéger le français à l'école
mais force est de constater que comme je
vous l'ai dit le français à l'école
soumis à beaucoup de spéculation
aujourd'hui laisser au maire
la possibilité de choisir qui construit
qui déclare où on le fait uniquement
sans aucun contre-pouvoir nous la
Chambre d'Agriculture ça nous paraît
dangereux pour la culture et on connaît
aussi le moi-même je suis élu dans une
commune sans cesse on reçoit des gens je
veux qu'on soit je veux construire je
veux déclasser puisque effectivement il
y a cette aspect spéculation donc
effectivement le président de la chambre
s'est exprimé il exprimait cette crainte
et la vie confonde vous conforme de la
CDPA pour nous il est prépondérant dans
le sens où il enlève de la pression sur
le mer au lieu de commission ou la
Chambre d'Agriculture n'est pas non plus
majoritaire on est que trois
représentants de la profession agricole
il y a trois élus il y a trois
associations écologistes et il y a
quatre voix de l'État mais ça permet en
tout cas de d'être un petit peu un
garde-fou par contre ce qu'on a toujours
demandé et qui est en voie
d'amélioration d'ailleurs depuis que la
secrétaire général madame PAM a pris la
présidence de la Commission on a vu
beaucoup d'améliorations c'est qui est
plus de discussion plus de souplesse
plus d'accompagnement pour que les
projets qui qui qui doivent aboutir qui
sont justifiés et ben ils puissent ils
puissent sortir donc voilà pour le le
premier thème sur la la
maintenant je viens sur les terres en
friche puisque c'est une proposition
froide qu'on a fait depuis plusieurs
années déjà donc le département est
volontaire
l'accompagnement les aides moi ce que je
dis toujours c'est la carotte et le
bâton donc la carotte est liée puisque
les agriculteurs les propriétés qui ont
été en friche qui décident de les louer
ou de les mettre à culture ils ont
aujourd'hui un accompagnement financier
une subvention de la part du Conseil
départemental mais par contre beaucoup
pensent des constater que beaucoup de
propriétaires et bien ils sont en
attente de spéculations ils se disent
que peut-être qu'au prochain plus le
maire va déplacer à l'école et je vais
toucher le super pote et de toute façon
à le louer à 800 euros l'hectare par an
ou à le vendre 1 euro du mètre carré
tant qu'à faire autant que je mette en
réserve et que j'attende 10 ans 15 ans
20 ans ou mes enfants ils vont
bénéficier du jackpot donc nous à la
Chambre d'Agriculture on pense que ce
n'est pas possible et qu'il faut
absolument quand on a le chiffre de 8000
hectares de terre qui sont en friche à
la Réunion et bah qu'on puisse et avoir
une incitation financière mais aussi
avoir une contrainte pour ses propriétés
qui décident de de spéculer on dit non
la spéculation il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui veulent s'installer à chaque terrain
ça fait il y a 7 jeunes qui postulent
pouvoir influencer l'école il faut
absolument qu'on trouve les outils donc
on attend la loi qu'elle nous apporte
des des éléments de réponse sur ce sujet
et donc voilà pour bien expliquer au
direct de la DAF qui qui était plutôt
contre cette proposition beaucoup de
terrain en friche sont mal de
propriétaire qui ont d'autres activités
qui ne sont plus agriculteurs donc c'est
VAE qu'en premier lieu on doit adresser
cette taxation ils ont déjà une activité
ils gagnent déjà du revenu ils ont pas
besoin de quelques milliers d'euros
supplémentaires mais par contre si le
français il est en attente et ben on les
taxe
ensuite sur la SAFER bon je vais laisser
la SAFER
répondre
sur les départs en retraite je pense que
le syndicat déjà l'agriculture qui est
présent vont contribuer mais
effectivement la spasa c'est quand même
une belle amélioration qui est proposée
dans la loi de retraite de augmenter le
plafond à 150000 au lieu de 200000 je
rappelle aussi que le français est
collègue exonéré par contre il manque il
manque d'informations à ce sujet et ça
arrive peut-être un peu tard à 65 ans la
profession récolte la proposition
qu'elle a toujours faite c'est de
remettre en place un système de
pré-retraite puisque comme vous le dites
l'agriculture et et vieillissante et ça
entraîne beaucoup de de problèmes et le
système de pré-retraite qui existait
auparavant qui était financé avec un
départ à partir de 57 ans et ben le
bilan était positif et on a un peu mal
compris pourquoi ce ce voilà cet outil
qui qui avait un intérêt à temps a été
supprimé du jour au lendemain donc nous
notre position c'est OUI à l'AFPA à 650
ça arrive un peu tard peut-être un outil
de retraite pour que le tuilage puisse
se faire plus plus vite puisque quand
l'agriculteur 65 ans c'est déjà ses
enfants ont déjà 30 ans et bien souvent
ils ont eu le temps d'aller vers un
autre métier ils vont pas attendre de 30
ans à ne rien faire donc ils sont à
notre métier et après c'est du foncier
qui qui repart en friche
sur l'eau donc bon je rejoins le
vice-prés dans l'agriculture et le
directeur de la gare donc aujourd'hui
l'enjeu s'est stocké les projets sont en
cours on accueille ici favorablement
l'annonce de l'état de d'accompagner le
projet méren
on a on est heureux aussi que le fait
d'air demain puisse accompagner les
solutions de stockage d'eau mais voilà
c'est un sujet où on a pris quand même
énormément de retard on a des périmètres
qui qui ont eu des gros projets donc le
guitare à l'ouest avec le grand chantier
de basculement le sud est très bien
réglé et aujourd'hui voilà le constat
fait que l'est une zone qui était
fortement arrosée auparavant et ben subi
aujourd'hui les conséquences de la
sécheresse qui cause beaucoup de
difficultés à relancer notre agriculture
donc voilà le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une harmonie sur le territoire
ou à chaque fois on est capable de
stocker la ressource qui est précieuse
et de la redistribuer donc là aussi on
attend un renforcement des outils
et enfin je vais revenir sur le dernier
sujet donc qui est le logement des
agriculteurs il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui on choisit la solution de
facilité la solution de facilité c'est
de dire aucune habitation à quelques
exceptions près sont autorisées sur le
frontal comme ça on prend au carré mais
malheureusement nous qui sommes
représentants des des exploitants
agricoles donc on voit tous les joueurs
des exploitations qui qui ferment qui
mettent la clé sous la porte à cause
d'une attaque de chien à cause de voir
la répétition à cause d'un manque de
suivi technique puisque la maison non
d'habitation principale et à 20-25 km de
l'exploitation on regarde aussi des
communes comme le temps de tampon qui
sont on va le dire très vite mais qui
malgré tout si on regarde la fée
souveraineté alimentaire et considéré
comme le grenier de la Réunion puisqu'il
y a beaucoup de petites exploitations
avec un local une exploitation de
maraîchage et qui permet de produire
beaucoup de valeur ajoutée donc oui nous
on n'est pas d'accord à ce que la porte
soit totalement ouverte mais de un feu
rouge total ben on le voit les
agriculteurs s'adaptent il y a des
constructions illégales et je peux vous
dire que les maires ont beaucoup de
difficultés à aller les dénoncer puisque
c'est un sujet qui est qui est très
tendu je rappelle 40 000 demandes de
logement donc nous les élus on accueille
pas très favorablement que demain on a
été démolir encore plus des des
constructions d'habitation dans une île
qui connaît déjà un gros problème de
logement donc il faut se mettre autour
de la table avec la DAF la Chambre
d'Agriculture a déjà commencé à faire un
travail peut-être des constructions
limitées à Maurice par exemple j'étais
en mission chaque exploitant agricole à
droite 30 mètres carrés d'un local de
surveillance pour pouvoir surveiller ses
exploitations il y a deux territoires où
il y a des des surfaces qui sont un peu
bridées pour éviter que il y a sur
concentration
on sollicite le PFR aussi pour
accompagner la SAFER lorsqu'il y a
transmission pour acheter les maisons
d'application et sur le PFR j'ai un
autre sujet aussi j'ai vu qu'en
métropole une agglomération avait réussi
à mettre son foncier à disposition des
interlocuteur on sait que le PFR fait
des portages très longs parfois 5 10 ans
ou le foncier qui qui agricole est
transformé en français économique par
exemple et porter pendant 5-10 ans avant
que le projet voit le jour et
aujourd'hui la réponse moi je suis à
l'EP fr aussi c'est que oui mais si on a
un agriculteur il aura du mal à sortir
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut dépasser
ce cette difficulté là et s'il y a une
contractualisation avec une date de fin
une date de début une date de fin et
bien pendant 5 6 7 ans on peut faire de
la production d'ananas sur un an de la
production légumière par on peut
contribuer à mettre ce foncier en valeur
donc voilà je sais que 10 minutes c'est
très court mais j'ai été en condensé de
de vous donner un petit peu le principal
et encore une fois je vous remercie de
votre intérêt
[Musique]
et des intrants les difficultés
des molécules agréés
des incertitudes nées à la nouvelle
convention au crâne et de nouveaux cas
des infirmières ne doivent être négliger
les hommes de carrière qui le reviennent
pas en agricole par la suite
beaucoup beaucoup de cas à la Réunion à
Saint-Pierre et à bras
que 2000 notifications dépenser le
batterie en zone
A et elle souvent sans permis
l'amélioration des connaissances des
risques naturels et des finitions et
précise les zonages qui réduisent de la
saü
et demain la mise en oeuvre de l'arrêté
préfectorale chez les hommes de nos
traitement risque fort d'accentuer les
frites et diminuer la salive
[Musique]
dans la continuité de ce qu'il a dit là
c'est qu'effectivement depuis la mise en
place des PPR les travaux d'amélioration
foncière ont été limitées dans certaines
zones ce qui a fait que ce sont des
ordres de des prises qui sont qui se
font mis en place il y a également dans
le cadre de la révision des plus sur les
éléments cartographiques qu'on a de
entre 2016 et 2020 à peu près 1000
hectares de terrains qui étaient en zone
agricole sont partis en zone naturelle
dans dans les plus et pour certains avec
des zonages en NBC alors malgré la mise
en place en termes de discussion d'une
doctrine sur les sur les EBC ces
zones-là existent et il est fort
compliqué de les remettre en agricole
alors ce qu'il faut prendre aussi en
considération c'est que tout à l'heure
on parlera des terres en friche pour
savoir si c'est possible de les taxer ou
pas nous on se dit
il faut aussi regarder l'autre côté de
la zone urbaine il y a des fruits
urbaines il y a aussi des hommes qui
sont en zone constructible depuis un
certain temps alors après avec des
problèmes particuliers que ce soit
l'indivision ou autre mais c'était un là
ne sont été anciennement des terres
agricoles qui ne sont pas valorisés par
du logement ou par des infrastructures
nous on se dit que voilà peut-être qu'il
faudrait aussi taxer ces hommes qui ne
sont pas devenus constructibles au bout
de 5 ans 10 ans
ou plus ou de les ramener tout bêtement
zone agricole ou en zone naturelle si il
n'y a aucun projet derrière alors après
on voit aussi tout à l'heure
[Musique]
Bruno Robert nous a parlé de de la zone
du tampon alors nous on aimerait citer à
un cas sur laquelle on est en train de
se pencher avec le Scott c'est la zone
de tampon la zone de Saint-Pierre qui
sont deux communes qui sont juste
contiguës ou voilà il faut surtout
trouver la cohérence parce que juste
avec une le chemin on a une zone tampon
qui a une zone agricole comme on l'a dit
assez fort avec de l'eau d'obligation et
juste en traversant la route on est sur
la commune du Tampon où on a une grosse
zone artisanale et je vous cache pas que
voilà ça traite la la convoitise et la
frustration et ça ça ce sont des hommes
également de des prises ou les
agriculteurs pensent que sur des petites
parcelles aujourd'hui inférieur à 1000
mètres carrés il est juste impossible de
faire l'agriculture donc que ces
terrains bientôt seront à caractère
spéculatif alors on a parlé également
des paon je pense que voilà cette
première sur la commune de la petite île
devrait être voilà étendu à l'ensemble
des communes de l'île surtout pour
protéger les bonnes terres entre autres
les terres qui ont été bénéficié de la
la mise en eau de l'irrigation et qui
seront éventuellement demain dans les
futurs périmètres
mais également il y a quelque chose qui
était obligé c'était le pro deo la mise
en eau des Hauts de la de la zone des
hauts il faut voilà il faut pas négliger
que demain si c'est périmètre là sont
mis en eau via des retenues de grande
capacité il faudra aussi également
inclure c'est ces hommes des eaux là
dans des dans des terres à
protéger et alors je fais le lien tout
de suite avec la CD bénaf ce qu'on
entend souvent c'est que voilà les gens
qui ont pour qui on a refusé les permis
de construire certains de construire de
façon illégale certains se disent même
si c'est pour avoir un refus mieux vaut
faire dans l'inégalité donc je pense
qu'il est il est nécessaire pour
protéger la SAI de l'huile c'est de
mettre en place des moyens de police
pour renforcer
le contrôle des constructions illégales
entre élément aussi important c'est que
on va parler des différents frites mais
en préambule la SAFER a mis en place une
offre de
d'accompagnement auprès des
collectivités sur les biens les biens
vacances ou les biens s'en mettre et ça
c'est voilà c'est un enjeu aussi
important parce que on se rend compte
que
un des éléments qui voilà qui favorise
la
le retour des terres en friche c'est le
fait que les indivisions ne soient pas
réglées et que certains terrains
n'ont plus de propriétaires connus par
la suite
en ce qui concerne le point 2
c'est-à-dire les terrains en friche sans
rentrer dans le détail parce que voilà
le département et la chambre on a parlé
comme l'a dit Monsieur Robert la carotte
c'est qu'effectivement le département a
bien joué le jeu en mettant en place des
primes alors des primes qui vont à la
vente des terrains ou à la location des
terrains mais également ce sont des
primes qui permettent en fin de compte
aux agriculteurs à titre principal qui
bénéficient de ce terrain là d'avoir un
remboursement des frais de notaire et
une garantie d'emprunt alors juste pour
2023 169 hectares 73 parcelles et
273000 euros
voilà de modifications apportées par par
le département en ce qui concerne
maintenant
la possibilité de passer alors en
relisant les textes je me suis rendu
compte que effectivement c'est une
possibilité qui était déjà ouverte
l'article 181-15 du code rural le
prévoyait et renvoie en fin de compte à
l'article 1639 à bis du Code Général des
Impôts c'est à dire que si les communes
font le recensement et que le
recensement est validé elle peut
transmettre l'information et la hauteur
de taux de taxes en fait compte au
service de l'État pour mettre en place
une taxation sur les terres qui sont en
friche
donc il appartient alors il appartient
en fin de compte aux communes de le
faire alors peut-être qu'il devrait le
faire en constatation avec bon on
appelle ça avec le Conseil départemental
qui aujourd'hui même la procédure était
dans un culte via
il y a comment
avec avec la SAFER alors juste un petit
paramètre que j'ai également oublié
[Musique]
concernant le mentalement et pour
revenir tout de suite à au construction
c'est que on se disait dans le cadre
d'une réflexion avec certains
partenaires c'est que si des
constructions de maisons qui bien sûr
lié nécessaire à l'activité agricole
était autorisé par la CD penave et
autorisé par la suite par le maire il
faudrait plutôt qu'on essaie de trouver
un moyen un peu comme le font les
affaires dans une disposition
réglementaire de mettre en place une
forme de cahier des charges ou le
propriétaire s'il doit demander le la
division il faut que tu demandes une
autorisation éventuellement à la à la
CDAF qui pourrait répondre via une
opposition sans forcément avoir à motivé
étant donné que ce projet de
construction là a été fait à un moment
donné pour une raison qui était
particulière il au lieu alors si on
n'arrive pas à trouver une solution sur
les constructions au cas par cas pour
chacune des exploitations
donc voilà
concernant les terrains à cultes
oui également concernant les terrains
cultes
bon le département a déjà mis des moyens
mais je pense que dans le dans le cadre
du ferder s'il y avait la possibilité
d'aider aux règlements des indivisions
des successions
que le coût des frais et super ailleurs
au prix des terrains agricoles ce qui
fait que quand on est sur des
indivisions compliqués
et que il y a énormément de personnes ça
pourrait permettre enfin voilà des fonds
fléchés peu importe de régler un certain
nombre d'indivisions alors concernant
l'optimisation du droit de prétention de
masse affaire alors deux trois éléments
alors les exemptions construction qui
sont
par la loi sur des surfaces de moins de
215 mètres carrés pour une construction
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est atteint
[Musique]
cet aspect là alors en sachant que bien
souvent après au bout de trois ans là ça
fait de voir les contrôler si ces
personnes ont obtenu un permis et on se
rend compte la plupart du temps dans
dans presque tous les cas de contrôle
que les personnes n'ont pas obtenu le
permis et là il faut entamer une
l'action au tribunal qui commence déjà
par une médiation ce qui fait que entre
temps pendant trois ans ce sont des
petites surfaces de terrain qui ont été
vendus à des non agriculteurs donc il
faudrait peut-être revoir le texte pour
dire que les options ne vaut que sur des
terrains à bâtir en zone éventuellement
à U ou sur des terrains qui sont
en zone U ou en partie en zone et en
partie en zone A mais non pas sur des
terrains qui sont essentiellement en a
et surtout en périgativité
il y a aussi concernant le drapeau c'est
de veiller à cette astuce qui est
utilisée sur le démembrement de la
propriété de dire que certains à chacun
du propriétaire et on est notifié d'un
usufruit viager et on se rend compte
qu'au bout de trois ans l'usufruit qui
était soi-disant viager et revendu ce
qui fait que la saphène ne peut plus ne
peut plus intervenir par rapport à au
caractère viager initial et on se
retrouve avec des noms d'agriculteurs
qui achètent des terrains agricoles il y
a aussi une astuce qui est aussi
utilisée c'est
la mise en place d'un bail en fibiotique
de 90 devant pour décourager l'exercice
de droit de prétention parce que la
personne après rachète qui est dans
l'agriculteur rachète le terrain
agricole en sachant que voilà cette
personne-là amphithéotique
on aura on aura du mal à intervenir en
prélantion puisque on aura du Rhin à
retrouver un agriculteur qui achètera
avec un terrain sur laquelle il y a un
bail ensuite de 99 ans
où cette personne-là aura quand même des
droits
concernant le droit de préemption
partielle pareil c'est
peut-être une bonne
réussite
au vu des délais et au vu des coups si
la SAFER ne peut pas demander une
révision de prix sur les terrains sur la
partie
ou sur la partie constructible c'est ce
qu'on appelle un coup d'épée dans l'eau
puisque en un mois bien souvent quand on
dit qu'on achète la partie agricole au
prix agricole et qu'on nous demande de
tout acheter en un mois on n'a jamais
les moyens de trouver un attributaire et
encore moins de mettre en place un
projet financier il y a aussi un autre
aspect c'est sur les adducation quand un
terrain est saisi c'est au plus offrant
et la plupart du temps le plus offrant
c'est pas un agriculteur donc il
faudrait qu'on trouve une
mécanisme pour que la ça fait plus se
mettre une offre qui couvre le prix
offre valider par les commissaires du
Gouvernement et que le terrain puisse
rester dans le monde agricole
voilà
concernant le financement alors la SAFER
a surtout deux rôles une mission de
service public et une mission de
répondre aux objectifs du législateur et
ses objectifs là sont transcrits dans le
PPS qui étaient qui validité par la
depuis 2014 les affaires ont été adossés
aux régions et il y avait 27 ça fait
dans certaines étant en difficulté
aujourd'hui il en a que 13 en métropole
et c'est ça faire là aujourd'hui en on
va dire un espace ou un marché qui va
permettre en fin de compte de remplir
ces deux missions c'est à dire mission
de service public et répondre aux
objectifs mais ça fait un homme ont été
entre guillemets des laissés pour compte
puisque malgré un rapport Chantal
Berthelot et avec Emma qui prévoyait
une recette fiscale dédiée aux affaires
sur une partie de la TSE rien n'a été
fait alors depuis quelques temps depuis
que j'ai pris la responsabilité du
groupe d'hommes on a relancé ce dossier
on a on était hier encore en visio avec
les l'outre-mer dont la présidente de la
SAFER Guyane aujourd'hui et nul autre
que Madame Chantal Berthelot on est en
train de remonter les dossiers on a pris
quelques contacts avec le ministère on
espère que voilà cette proposition de
financement qui soit pérenne et qui
de répondre un à la merci de service
public et deux d'accompagner entre
autres les jeunes à l'installation
de faire du portage
la loi de chimie
selon le dernier colloque du Conseil
supérieur du notariat de la Réunion il
n'y a pas de règlement d'indivision sur
ce sera le connu via cette loi
on est sur une une posture qui dit que
la question de l'application des
dispositions de la loi qui vise à
faciliter la sortie de l'indivision
successorale et à relancer la politique
du logement en grande outre-mer et des
terres agricoles par nature ou des
bâtiments d'exploitation autre que les
logements se posent sur des questions de
successions ouvertes à littérature
juridique a tendance à dire que la seule
cause d'ouverture d'une succession et de
le décès et non le fait de saisir le
notaire pour le régler donc il faudrait
qu'on puisse préciser en fin de compte
les textes qui ont inspiré cette loi
l'alchimie alors qu'on fait dans la CdP
on va dire que tout a été dit
voilà
concernant l'adresse effectivement
il y a un gros et un gros défi
puisqu'on dit presque un quart des des
agriculteurs ont un âge assez certain
qui qui mériterait voilà un départ en
retraite pour une installation
mais on se rend compte effectivement que
les départs en retraite ne sont pas
seulement de 65 ans parce que vu le
montant de la retraite on a encore signé
il y a pas longtemps la vente d'un
terrain d'un agriculteur qui est parti
en retraite à 82 ans pour pouvoir
installer son fils derrière donc si le
montant de la retraite revue je pense
que ça pourrait permettre voilà des
départs en retraite pour des
installations et éventuellement pourquoi
pas remettre le dispositif incitatif de
la loom pour les départs en pré-retraite
ou éventuellement de voilà primer les
départs en retraite pour des
installations ou des ventes de terrain à
la SAFER qui permettraient
l'installation d'un jeune le manque
d'eau tout a été dit on a juste que
voilà comme on a dit c'est plutôt un
problème de gestion je pense que là le
département est dans une stratégie
mereng une stratégie pro deo et un
modèle des grandes retenues sur la
commune de du tampon qu'il faut il on
continue à appuyer et concernant alors
le PFR
loan9 là ça fait de la Réunion enfin on
est on va dire qu'on est bons amis et
voisins respectueux
je suis de près les travaux
de la Martinique et de la Guadeloupe tu
utilises en fin de compte le PFR soit du
portage on a quelques communes
aujourd'hui qui veulent développer
l'agroforesterie qui souhaite acheter
des terrains dans un naturel alors là ça
fait un a pas trop les moyens de faire
du portage pour mettre en place les
projets si le PFR voulait bien nous
accompagner pour l'acquisition de ce
terrain en zone naturelle
pour qu'on puisse ensuite retrousser
bien ce terrain aux communes sur des
projets d'installation des projets de
complément d'installation sur des
projets
liés à ces zones environnementales alors
que ce soit papa
cacao vanille apiculture ou
éventuellement d'autres plantes de sous
on a été en voyage effectivement en
Guadeloupe on a vu que voilà l'ONF lancé
des appels à projets sur ce secteur là
sur des terrains qui ont été achetés des
terrains qui étaient déjà sous gestion
onef ou éventuellement des terrains qui
sont achetés par la SAFER et qui sont
revendus aux communes via le PF
j'attends le retour des conventions
capitaine pour faire des propositions le
pH de la Réunion en espérant qu'on aura
le même succès voilà pour ce qui est de
cet aspect alors juste un autre aspect
aussi important
attention entre les outre-mer sur les
terrains les autorisations des fichiers
étaient la même j'ai appris de mes
collègues de martiniquais
en danser dans dans ces deux
départements
qui sensation pour obtenir un avis de de
défricher nous ce qu'on avait demandé
puisque c'est un sujet qu'on a discuté
avec le ministère d'outre-mer c'est que
sur les zones a qui sont déjà placé en
vocation agricole dans les plumes on ne
soit pas soumise à l'autorisation
défricher que non soit soumis à
autorisation des fichiers seulement sur
les zones N ou dans certains inclus
l'activité peut être activité agricole
peut être compatible d'autant plus que
la DAF aujourd'hui accorde
l'autorisation de défricher sous réserve
des dispositions du code de
l'environnement
et faut-il ponctuellement autoriser
l'habitation sur les propriétaires
agricoles je pense que tout a été dit
voilà si c'est lié nécessaire et que il
y a pas possibilité de diviser
l'exploitation le morcellement par la
suite et que c'est des projets que le
bien est revendu un agriculteur on n'est
pas contre
très bien merci beaucoup messieurs avant
de passer la parole à Monsieur Léonard
de l'ONF je crois que Monsieur le
vice-président du conseil départemental
a demandé la parole monsieur Hoarau il a
peut-être quelques infos je voulais
juste abonder merci madame la sénatrice
de me redonner la parole sur la
protection des terres agricoles vous
savez il y a plusieurs outils
réglementaires bien sûr le règlement des
de nos plans locaux Giovanni qui font la
base même de la protection des terres
agricoles et après il y a des outils qui
existent qui viennent conforter
peut-être même aussi mettre dans le
marbre inscrire dans le marbre ces
surfaces agricoles au niveau communal
les mers peuvent s'engager dans la
définition de zone agricoles protégées
des fameuses apps et puis au département
nous avons eu nous portons cette
ambition de mettre en place les paon Pen
carapellé le vice-président de la
Chambre d'Agriculture il faut savoir que
sur le territoire de La Réunion
actuellement 6 communes sont entrées
dans cette démarche et je rappelle la
démarche paen ce n'est pas c'est juste
pour bien délimiter des espaces pour
lesquels les mères et le département
souhaitent véritablement
marqué le caractère agricole de de des
secteurs concernés le paon n'est pas
assorti d'une réglementation c'est bien
ce sont bien les PLU qui restent je
dirais le document
réglementaire mais le paon donc a une
force puisque pris à un niveau national
décret donc forcément il a effectivement
un poids avec un plan d'action qui est
décliné pour pouvoir faire vivre les
paon donc nous en avons 6 sur le
territoire de La Réunion et je remercie
président de l'histoire de la chambre
d'avoir mis en avant cet outil du
département et effectivement le que je
suis a été le premier à la réunion de
d'abonder dans le sens du conseil
départemental pour véritablement faire
en sorte que cet outil puisse être
efficace et protège le foncier de nos
agriculteurs qui est leur outil de
travail juste un petit bémol mais je
pense que la Chambre a bien compris
aujourd'hui l'intérêt dommage que ce
paon a petit-il obtenu un avis réservé
de la chambre mais je vois que les
choses évoluent dans le bon sens et
c'est tant mieux parce que ça reste pour
moi le meilleur outil pour préserver et
valoriser les espaces agricoles de notre
territoire à la Réunion
très bien merci Monsieur le
vice-président pour ce complément
d'information et pour terminer donc je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur Sylvain
Léonard directeur régional de l'ONF
puisque monsieur Guillaume sellier pour
le syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs
viennent de s'excuser il ne pourra être
avec nous et mais il nous a envoyé ses
réponses par écrit monsieur Léonard
c'est à vous
merci donc bon la forêt est un rôle un
petit peu marginal par rapport à
l'ensemble des questions qui ont été
posées cependant un rôle très important
je dirais en amont et notamment sur le
sur le régime hydrique donc en de façon
générale donc le NF gère la Réunion
100000 hectares de forêts publiques
c'est une surface importante de ça
représente 40% du territoire de Lille
c'est avec un statut foncier un peu
particulier puisque 90% de la forêt que
nous gérons que République et sous
statut de forêt départementaux de
maniable statue qui date de 1946 à la
loi de départements de 46 portée par
Aimé Césaire dans lequel le département
est mieux propriétaire et l'État est
usufruitier avec un gestionnaire de
droite qui est qui est le nez qui ont
fait une gestion comme une je dirais une
vraie fausse forêt domaniale avec un
relationnel très fort avec un écoute
très forte et un onvénient très
important du département
d'un système ou de protection forte
par contre pardon en matière de
défrichement éventuel parce que c'est un
terrain qui est né aliénable
et qui est renforcé par le fait que 80%
de la départementale de la Réunion et
également constituent également le parc
national qui est inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO pour deux critères
le critères biodiversité critère paysage
donc
un peu je voudrais essentiellement
insister sur le rôle au-delà de la
surface qui est importante sur le rôle
que représente cette forêt d'une part en
matière
géographique ou topographique la forêt
c'est essentiellement les hauts de la
Réunion donc sur des terrains avec une
très forte pente donc il serait il ne
serait pas ou très peu possible
d'utiliser pour l'agriculture et d'autre
part ça représente le château d'eau de
la Réunion on peut facilement comparer
la situation entre la Réunion et Mayotte
avec Mayotte la motivation
catastrophique en matière d'alimentation
en eau alors que les 100 000 hectares de
forêt départementaux de Mayenne vous ne
ferait le public sont le principal
facteur de régulation du régime hydrique
et de qui permet d'alimenter d'alimenter
les nappes phréatiques et le réduire
l'impact en matière d'érosion des fortes
pluies dans les donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle les indemnités environnementales
qui sont produites à la forêt vous avez
un sujet qui a été évoqué à plusieurs
reprises et les friches il y a pas
réellement de friches en forêt en forêt
public nous avons des zones qui sont
parfois des zones agricoles donc soit
que l'on gère en direct notamment en
matière d'élevage je prends par exemple
la plaine la plaine des Cafres où nous
avons des conventions de l'occupation
temporaires d'éleveurs ce sont des
conventions qui sont négociées dans les
années 80
forcément à la à l'arrêt de l'activité
de de Gauvain du wagon en forêt et donc
chaque agriculteur a pu récupérer une
convention de toute façon temporaire aux
alentours de 40 hectares par éleveur qui
se sont regroupés en coopérative nous
avons aussi la situation
très particulière du cirque de Mafate ou
en fait sur les 800 habitants permanents
du cirque de Mafate une bénéficient de
convention d'occupation temporaire pour
habitation pour élevage pour culture
pour activité commerciale et enfin dans
certains cas le département nous a
demandé de récupérer en toute propriété
des terrains qui étaient à vocation
agricoles qui étaient en fin
départemental pour le pour en avoir un
usage directement ce que nous avons fait
avec deux opérations qui sont une qui
est terminée donc qui est en cours là
qui est donc les 15 agricoles sur les
ponts salés et l'autre la prenne des
Gregs qui est en cours donc ce sont des
zones qui sont destinées principalement
de l'élevage et que le département donc
gérera après après directement donc en
fait on n'a pas réellement de zone de
friche en forêt on a beaucoup évoqué
également le l'agrophoristerie donc il y
a un élément assez important également à
la Réunion le produit phare ou la
production phare c'est la vanille
concentré dans le sud de Lille sur les
communes de Saint-Philippe et
Sainte-Rose où nous gérons
environ 200 mentions d'occupation
temporaire destinées à la vanille et de
façon diffuse son ensemble du territoire
l'apiculture sont des conventions
également d'occupation
ce sont les deux seuls j'ai réactivités
forestières que l'on développe on a
développé avant d'être à la Réunion
j'étais directeur régional pour LEF en
Martinique donc on a été éliminé au
début des demandes de la coléité
territoriale pour faire des
l'agroforesterie en matière de cacao et
j'étais assez prudent puisque en fait
les plans de cacao au départ peuvent
être sous couvert forestier mais
rapidement besoin de lumière et faire de
la grosse foresterie de cacao ou de café
il faut être conscient que ça se
terminera par un changement d'usage du
sol donc ça se terminera par de la forêt
qui viendra était à la terre agricole
donc on est conscience faut savoir si on
veut cette démarche mais ce sera pas de
l'agroforesterie au même titre au titre
par exemple de la vanille ou de
l'apiculture qui elle est vraiment une
valorisation de la forêt sans risque de
changement d'usage du sol peut-être un
dernier élément on a évoqué également le
classement l'espace où les éclaté dans
les documents d'urbanisme souvent l'ONF
fait les remarques que l'espace doit
déclasser de classement d'espace boisé
classés de forêts publics qui ici déjà
de leur statut de protection
associée à la forêt de manière
départementaux de Manial
alors que l'espace boisé classé est
censé être une mesure de protection
contre l'urbanisation donc qui devrait
vous notre fenêtre est limité à une
application sur des terrains privés que
la commune souhaite conserver en forêt
mais il y a redondance en fait de mettre
un classement de l'espace boisé classé
sur la forêt public qui est déjà
largement largement protégée
merci à vous donc je suis à votre
disposition pour les questions
merci beaucoup monsieur et bien écoutez
ah j'ai notre collègue monsieur Delmont
sénateur de la Réunion qui souhaiterait
également vous poser quelques questions
chers collègues c'est à vous
[Musique]
ce matin je suis un petit peu avec des
bouts sur les à vous entendre et
j'écoutais avec beaucoup d'attention
siaro salut Serge
dans l'exercice difficile
qu'il a pu avoir aujourd'hui en tant que
vice-président sur les affaires d'école
du conseil départemental mais aussi
président de l'association des maires
et c'est vrai que c'est on
n'est pas en guerre les maires avec la
culture ou quoi que ce soit mais quoi
qu'il en soit les intérêts
et je rappelle une chose principe de
fondamental c'est que le maire
responsable de l'organisation spatiale
de sa commune
et donc depuis pas mal de temps les mers
ont été dépouillés donc beaucoup de leur
pouvoir et aujourd'hui l'autre cette
réunion je vois que vous voulez en
condépouiller de plus en plus les mers
je ne suis plus mais à donc
je suis pas intéressé à titre personnel
mais c'est vrai que
de plus en a une des contraintes qui se
contredisent la demande de logement
il y a beaucoup de lois qui qui s'empile
doit littoral la protéine
loi paysage loi montagne Espagne naturel
tout et là moi il y a un sujet
je suis moi vent debout contre satanique
conforme
parce que nous ne sommes pas une
exception outre-mer par rapport donc la
population française ou la vie n'est que
consultatif
Monsieur le Directeur
vous avez parlé de 5000 dossiers
combien il favorable ont été donnés
je suis un dossier d'agriculteur en ce
moment que je ne serai pas le nom et
j'ai vu votre questionnaire
il est à sa troisième demande
et je crois que pour répondre à votre
questionnaire il faut être expert en
tout
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
agriculteurs
et donc c'est pour ça que je suis vend
de vous contre cette cet habit conforme
ou alors que vous ayez un peu plus de
souplesse parce que il paraît-il
beaucoup de lobbying pour faire passer
un dossier mais il faut des années faire
passer un dossier donc c'est pour ça que
je suis pas d'accord donc certaines
positions
ou de la chambre ou de
DAF ou autre et donc peut-être que
beaucoup plus de souplesse et de laisser
quand même un peu de pouvoir au maire
dans leur décision de leur projet de
leur commune
pour l'instant beaucoup de produits sont
bloqués suite à votre avis négatif voilà
donc si je touche à ce point là que je
voulais intervenir
bon je ne sais pas si vous avez des
précisions à porter un monsieur le
sénateur
sinon je vais moi-même vous poser
j'aurai quatre questions à vous poser
une question oui
juste pour réagir si c'est possible je
vous en prie allez-y
on soit bien d'accord la CD Bénard a
deux rôles un statut tous les mois sur
les dossiers individuels des porteurs
projets mais un rôle que souvent on ne
voit pas on que met pas en lumière c'est
qu'elle se positionne aussi sur les PLU
les documents d'urbanisme qui sont
portés par les mains et souvent ce qu'on
voit c'est que les PLU arrivent avec des
demandes par exemple de
un chiffre au hasard une commune va
demander 1000 hectares de déclassement
et après échange avec la CD pennaf on
arrive à
atterrir sur 400 500 hectares donc enfin
je sais pas si la DAF peut confirmer ce
que je dis mais nous en tout cas la
Chambre d'Agriculture c'est sur ce volet
là en tout cas qu'on est très concentré
puisque quand on voit que des communes
arrivent avec 1000 hectares de surfaces
à bâtir et bien on se dit que Ben en
quelques années qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ce sera donc voilà bien dissocier
les deux dossiers et sur les demandes
individuelles bien souvent ce qui bloque
pour les dossiers qui pourraient sortir
c'est le manque d'accompagnement et moi
je connais bien les communes aujourd'hui
non plus de services agricoles digne de
ce nom pour accompagner les agriculteurs
c'est une prestation que la Chambre
d'Agriculture a mis en place mais qui
n'est pas que tous les deux potes de
projets ne sollicitent pas mais en tout
cas le premier motif pour les deux
individuels c'est le manque de
complétude du dossier des fois on a même
pas la preuve que la personne qui dépose
une demande de permis de construire dans
un agricole et agriculteur ou
agricultrice donc en commission c'est
difficile quand on a pas les éléments de
voter le sujet donc vraiment voilà je
voulais resituer un petit peu le le
débat là-dessus parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet qui est très complexe et
qui est très tendu
merci Monsieur personne d'autre ne veut
intervenir là-dessus sur ce dossier non
donc si vous le permettez moi je vais
vous poser quatre petites questions
j'aimerais savoir si la superficie
agricole permet à la Réunion d'être
autonome sur le plan alimentaire
est-ce que les normes européennes sont
adaptées à votre agriculture et si oui
est-ce que bon c'est bon si c'est non
est-ce que les normes européennes
peuvent être un frein aussi pour
l'installation de certains agriculteurs
mettre vraiment le pied à l'étrier aux
jeunes à qui ça permettrait aussi de
voir que vraiment ce métier lui plaît et
qu'il est prêt à se lancer il serait
peut-être un peu soutenu il serait
peut-être plus
à l'aise pour se lancer là-dedans et ça
ferait un petit complément de loyer et
enfin la retraite de la personne
âgée je ne sais pas si cela est mis en
place et si vous pensez que ça pourrait
être une bonne chose comment ça
fonctionne je vous remercie alors je ne
sais pas qui veut alors je crois que
c'est Monsieur Hoarau qui veut pas de la
parole
oui merci de me donner la parole sur le
dernier sujet concernant les jeunes
je pense que en nourrit un projet de
créer une ferme départementale
il serait quelque part un sas entre la
fin de de la formation et l'entrée
véritablement du jeûne dans la vie
active d'agriculteurs ou encore je le
dis d'exploitant
d'agriculteurs ou encore de d'ouvriers
agricoles parce que je crois que il faut
qu'on soit certain que ces jeunes qui
sortent de nos formations ont vraiment
la passion pour le métier de
l'agriculteur et vraiment la passion
pour demain être
des acteurs de ce métier noble qui est
agriculteur donc pour moi ça c'est
important on a ce projet et je reviens
sur ce que je disais tout à l'heure
l'idée de faire un tutorat ou un
compagnonnage entre un agriculteur en
fin de carrière et un jeune qui a cette
motivation pour devenir exploitant
agricole me paraît aussi une vraie
solution parce que ça garantirait la
reprise d'exploitation et ça assurerait
agriculteur qui partiraient à la
retraite d'avoir un véritable repreneur
de son siège exploitation et de son
exploitation donc moi je crois que c'est
là dessus absolument qui qui nous faut
insister trouver ce tutorat trouver ce
compagnonnage
identifier les agriculteurs en fin de
carrière qui n'ont pas forcément de
repreneur dans le réseau familial au
sein de sa propre famille mais
identifier des jeunes susceptibles de de
les accompagner donc il faut pas
attendre qu'il ait 67 ans le
compagnonnage doit se faire entre 60 et
67 ans ou 65 ans ou 64 ans tout dépend
du nombre d'années mais en toute état de
cause je pense que ça pourrait être un
bon tuilage entre à quelqu'un qui part
et quelqu'un qui arrive donc ça me
paraîtrait vraiment intéressant et
peut-être aussi dans la chasse se fait
avoir la possibilité de louer cet été ou
de pas forcément de vendre de faire
aussi de la location et essayer de le
montant de la location de terres
agricoles parce que ça aussi c'est une
bouchée de pain étant moi-même
cogérant d'un GFA agricole 10 hectares
c'est 6500 euros annuels à la Réunion ce
que rapporte en fermage ce cette
propriété foncière donc ça c'était
important sur votre première question
vous voulez bien me la reformuler s'il
vous plaît est-ce que la superficie
agricole à la Réunion vous permet d'être
autonome alors je n'aime pas ce terme
autonome je parle moi je suis mémoire
dans le schéma de parler de souveraineté
alimentaire pourquoi parce que faire
d'autonomie alimentaire ça voudrait dire
qu'on soit capable de produire tout ce
qu'on mange je suis le territoire ce qui
est faux d'abord et pour moi quand je
parle de souveraineté alimentaire c'est
l'action les produits sur les produits
essentiels oui puisque pour pouvoir
faire du maraîchage et répondre aux
besoins de de Réunionnaises et des
Réunionnais je pense qu'avec je vais
être très large 1000 hectares de culture
sous serre commentaires permettrait de
nourrir une bonne partie de la
population Inès si ce n'est toute la
totalité donc mais ça c'est en termes de
fruits et légumes en termes d'élevage on
a encore la capacité aussi de développer
cette un nombre d'élevages mais je vous
parle moi de souveraineté parce que si
on commence à parler parce que moi je
reste persuadé que la canne doit rester
l'agriculture pivot la culture pivot de
l'agriculture réunionnaise et de son
modèle agricole mais par contre on a
aujourd'hui d'autres besoins comme les
céréales comme le riz et cette souverain
est alimentaire je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à la construire avec les
pays de la zone Océan Indien qui ont des
territoires beaucoup plus vastes et
c'est tout simplement une véritable
coopération qui doit peut-être mis en
place avec la mise en oeuvre de
savoir-faire de de moyens humains
également donc ça pour moi c'est un
sujet qui qui va revenir ce sujet de la
souveraineté alimentaire
mais il y a capacité à la réunion de
faire un certain nombre de production on
peut pas tout faire mais on peut faire
une grande partie de ce dont on a besoin
je pense aux tomates à la courgette aux
oignons à l'ail après après je le redis
là où il y a beaucoup de main d'oeuvre
nécessité nécessite beaucoup de main
d'oeuvre il y a d'autres pays voisins
qui pourraient être nos être avec nous
sur sur le cet objectif de souveraineté
alimentaire donc c'est c'est c'était sur
ces deux questions que moi je souhaitais
répondre
merci beaucoup y a-t-il d'autres
personnes qui souhaitent répondre sur la
grooturisme donc oui monsieur monsieur
je crois que c'est parodie
la mer
je reviens juste sur deux points
compléter l'autonomie alimentaire ou la
souveraineté puisque le mot juste c'est
souffrenté nous avons un produit frais
j'entends pas en produit transformé nous
sommes par exemple suffisants en
production d'oeufs nous sommes quasi
suffisants en production de volailles et
employer les légumes nous devons être de
l'ordre de 70% de suffisance sur l'île
mais bien évidemment il y a des marges
de progrès mais le
on n'aura jamais une la production de
toutes les
de toutes les productions sur il faut il
faut que on se concentre sur les
productions qui sont adaptées à notre
territoire bien évidemment sur les
normes européennes puisque vous nous
avez interrogé sur les normes
européennes
je répondrai
on vous entend plus monsieur
[Musique]
ça y est c'est bon je crois ça y est
c'est bon c'est revenu
merci donc je disais qu'il y a une
différence entre les normes européennes
qui sont appliquées à la Réunion et les
normes des autres pays de l'Océan Indien
qui sont nos pays voisins que ce soit en
matière de coût du travail que ce soit
en matière d'utilisation d'un cran et
effectivement là-dessus c'est pas la
norme européenne qui nous gêne c'est
c'est la
défaut de concurrence entre les les pays
proches on a une vraie difficulté
puisque vous vous posez la question sur
l'utilisation des produits phytos ou on
a des produits phytos qui sont autorisés
en Europe et sur l'hexagone en
particulier des désherbants sur maïs
qu'on ne peut pas utiliser sur la canne
parce que c'est considéré comme une
production mineure et que c'est pas la
faute à la norme européenne c'est la
faute aux fabricants qui ne veulent pas
déposer de dossiers d'autorisation pour
ces produits qui sont indispensables
à la culture de la carte voilà je
voulais répondre sur ces sur ces deux
points de la
souveraineté alimentaire et sur la norme
européenne
merci monsieur je donne la parole à
Monsieur Bruno Robert qui a levé la main
aussi
oui madame la sénatrice effectivement
donc je vais dans la continuité de ce
qui a été dit auparavant donc
effectivement sur la souveraineté la
sécurité alimentaire on estime que les
chiffres sont déjà plutôt bons sur le
marché du frais mais qu'on peut encore
s'améliorer après c'est vrai qu'il y a
un facteur qui est important si elle
joue un rôle disait c'est les habitudes
de consommation les rayonner mangent de
la pomme mangent du raisin mange du riz
et on va bien que notre territoire n'est
pas appliqué tropical n'est pas adapté à
ses habitudes de consommation européenne
donc ça c'est une chose donc il fait
dire qu'on pourra
jamais être à 100% produire 100% ce
qu'on consomme par contre moi je note
quand on regarde les chiffres par
contiennent filières qui qui interpelle
c'est la filière agrume donc où le
terroir justement était appétissier qui
est en difficulté et où les
suite au greening on voit que les VAG
ont été arrachés et la plantation a pris
la place mais c'est vrai que la
difficulté sur ces ou le retour sur
investissement est très long moi
j'estime que au niveau de la chambre on
estime qui manque de d'accompagnement
puisque c'est très facile de mettre une
culture annuelle en place ou une culture
à ce 18 mois comme de l'ananas ou un
retour sur investissement va être très
rapide mais notre petite nos petits
exploitations ont du mal à se projeter
sur des cultures il faut attendre 4-5
ans avant d'avoir un revenu donc à mon
avis là-dessus ça mérite une réflexion
et un dispositif qui soit qui soit
adapté sur le les contraintes le DAF a
dit quelque chose de très important
c'est le combat du moment c'est sur les
molécules donc effectivement on est en
outre-mer un pays tropical qui est très
exposé aux champignons les herbes tous
très vite voilà on a besoin de solution
mais on est payé européen et ce qui
homologué pour notre meilleure batterie
là la France et ben n'est pas homologué
les firmes de l'homologues pas pour le
le
tropicale la Réunion donc ça nous pose
beaucoup de problèmes et sur la filière
Cannes j'allais il y a quand même
aujourd'hui en grosse difficulté par
manque de solutions on le voit que on
les les rendements à l'état les volumes
de Cannes à portée ce sont dégradés trop
fortement effectivement il y a une
partie de météo mais nous professions
agricole on on dit et on redit que
malheureusement les agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui démoni de solutions
techniques pour pouvoir atteindre des
performances qui le permettent d'être
pérenne dans le dans le temps sur la
gros tourisme la grille tourisme
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
redémarre qui qui a un intérêt sur toi
après cette période de covid ou les
touristes reviennent mais malgré tout on
en revient assez d'épinards il faut et
la chambre d'ailleurs et moteur sur ce
sujet avec des équipes qui font des
études à vie touristiques des
prestations de constructivité ou à
montrer que le projet viable mais il y a
toujours cette crainte que l'agriculture
il annonce vouloir faire de la grippe
mais il annonce surtout vouloir
construire et que derrière ce qui s'est
passé par le passé la Dark nous le
répète sans cesse les agriculteurs ont
demandé après la vie tourisme et
finalement ils ne l'ont pas exploités
ils ont utilisé comme maison principale
ou secondaire ou location donc là aussi
je reviens sur il faut peut-être des
moyens de suivre ça de contrôler mais de
fermer la porte c'est pas la solution il
faut se pencher pour essayer de trouver
une solution parce que c'est quand même
des revenus complémentaires qui
renforcent le modèle global de
l'exploitation agricole
très bien je vous remercie y a-t-il
quelqu'un qui souhaite prendre la parole
apporter des informations
complémentaires
je n'envoie pas donc écoutez messieurs
je vais vous dire un grand merci pour
toutes les informations que vous nous
avez communiqué n'hésitez pas à nous
faire part par écrit de vos suggestions
de vos propositions ou si vous avez
oublié de nous signaler quelque chose
nous sommes bien évidemment preneurs de
tout ce que vous pourriez nous apporter
comme informations merci beaucoup
messieurs et puis je vous souhaite une
excellente journée sous le soleil de la
Réunion
merci
au revoir merci